each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so my name is Indian she and I'm a
researcher from Microsoft Research
Silicon Valley so thank you for
attending the faculty submit and also
this session so in this session we are
going to examine a very stress targeting
online services and as we all know with
the user data applications increasingly
moving to the cloud QT is critical to
ensure pose the end users security as
well as a successful large-scale
services so we're going to discuss the
speakers going to present a set of
attacks raging from for example attack
creation account creation hijacking
attacks to those that abuse or changing
online advertising channels as well as
very sophisticated side channel attacks
in cloud computing environments and the
speakers are also going to discuss some
opportunities for attack detection and
defense and so our first speaker is
Roberson robert is applied research
manager from windows life safety
platform team and his team is developing
a lot of protection mechanism for entire
windows life and so his team has a lot
of first hand and a deep insight into
attacks going on targeting windows life
and they are working closely with
multiple other teams including hotmail
messenger and other windows like
divisions for developer for developing
technologies protect directly protect
end users for example I small screen
technologies etc and so our robot is
going to talk about attacks and defenses
in this area and he got PhD from McGill
University alright can everyone hear me
sound is good okay so thanks very much
for the introduction in the end I think
she described what we do reasonably well
we're responsible we're relatively small
research team within the windows live
safety platform but the platform itself
is responsible for a wide range of
Windows Live properties and also
shipping intelligence algorithms as they
relate to phishing and malware filtering
in IE so let me just dive right in I
what I'd like to do is just give you
kind of the 30,000 foot view of the
state of the ecosystem when it comes to
internet service security I'll talk a
little bit about defenses and trends but
really it's just to give you a sense of
how we're thinking about the problem
space and what's happening out there so
here are some numbers that should make
your head spin these are annual numbers
these are estimates but we think that
there's about ninety three trillion spam
messages sent annually including three
trillion dollar attachments and those
results in about 2.1 billion malware
downloads not to mention hundreds of
millions of page views on malicious
websites and and phishing page views as
well one of my slides is hidden excuse
me
up
i'm looking at a different deck excuse
me okay and these numbers hit closer to
home as well just in the last month we
saw linkedin leak six and a half million
passwords the internet a harmony was
compromised last.fm the day I posted
these slides yahoo disclosed a breach of
450,000 accounts and the list goes on
sony gawkers apples so this has been a
serious problem for the industry as a
whole let me back up my slides are out
of order is probably my fault so the big
number actually the one that worries us
most is that roughly half a million
accounts per day have their credentials
stolen across the industry and this
affects everybody every major internet
service is I'm not speaking specifically
about Windows Live but all the major
providers and this is very very painful
for users the vast majority of
compromise cases result in spam being
sent to their contacts and so the user
is first of all embarrassed and then
they have to jump through some very
painful hoops to recover their account
they need to remember their secret quest
and secret answer they need to remember
the birth date that they probably lied
about when they registered for the
service things like this so why
compromise this is a relatively new
problem in the spam domain it started
about 2 2008 where it became a real
trend real concern for us and largely it
comes from just better spam filtering
it's less cost effective today to create
hundreds of thousands or millions of
spam accounts and use them to get URLs
into the users in boxes so instead
attackers will hijack reputation they'll
take over a user's account and then take
advantage of the social network and the
good reputation of the account to get
spam into the inbox on top of that
there's across the whole industry
there's there's been an increase a
dramatic increase in the stored value in
an inbox users the inbox is kind of the
key location
password resets from a variety of
high-value services their receipts and
so on start in the inbox so if you can
gain control of someone's account you
have the opportunity to use their their
email account us as a leaping off point
to engage in much higher value attacks
so I'll talk a little bit about the
attackers themselves and then we can
start to talk a little bit about how we
contend with the problem and some of the
trends that we're seeing so generally
speaking attackers come from a wide
range of personalities or personas and
the ones that were most concerned about
our black hats actually at least in the
context of service abuse script kiddies
are a nuisance there are many many of
them they download tool kits they have
very little or limited technical
expertise no business acumen at all they
cause they cause pain but not very much
pain black hats on the other hand are
professional criminals it's organized
crime basically they have a lot of
business sense they have R&D resources
technical expertise and they take
advantage of services provided by gray
Hut's which are ostensibly legitimate
services in many cases not always or
quazy legitimate services gray hats are
not necessarily breaking the law with
the services they provide a good example
is captcha solving services that you can
find it on places like freelance calm so
there's this an evolving kind of
infrastructure of serious criminals and
support infrastructure that helps them
at the far end are kind of the groups
that tend to make the news they're small
and number they can be technically
sophisticated but the skit the scale and
scope of the damage they do against
specific Internet services tends to be
limited with the exception possibly of
corporate espionage and state-sponsored
attacks that are mainly geared at
disrupting specific business
interest so if it should becoming
apparent now that really what we're
fighting especially when we talk about
black cats is an ecosystem it's not
hackers it's not script kiddies it's a
it's an industry with business models
there's a high degree of specialization
in the industry there are people that
specialize in account harvesting people
that specialize in getting spam into the
inbox people that specialize in renting
out botnets and doing geo-targeted abuse
proxies and things like this and this
ecosystem is very very adaptive they
have the resources to turn on a dime to
fix things when we make a major service
change will break all of their scripts
and automation and they'll go out and
they'll you know within 24 hours they'll
be back on on the horse basically
continuing in their attack in the last
few years we've seemed a fair amount of
consolidation and trend towards criminal
or do I call it crime where as a service
so abusers have set up their own
internet portals or own self serve sites
where you can just basically go online
and get the geo-targeted botnet that you
want you don't necessarily have to deal
face to face with the criminals that
you're working with so I haven't if I
haven't made it clear yet I think it
should be clear now that really abuses
an economics problem definitely there
are technical elements to it but when we
think about how we want to mitigate
abuse and online crime we really we try
to think about the problem space in
terms of how can we increase cost two
attackers and how can we decrease their
revenue so some good examples is how can
we increase the cost of creating
distributing malware getting it to users
in boxes reduce click-through rates when
it does reach the inbox if we can
increase the cost of solving and into
individual CAPTCHA we would increase the
cost of creating new spammer accounts
and likewise when an account is
suspended because it's obviously abusive
we can demand things like SMS proofs and
other costs proofs to ensure that the
attacker is paying some penalty or some
price for regaining control of the
account and on the flipside we want to
decrease their revenue so what are the
ways we can limit the extent to which
they can scale out their attacks how can
we decrease the value of a compromise
machine and the data thats stolen from
it and decrease the value of URLs of
savage the inbox these are some numbers
that come from various sources they give
you a sense of kind of weather spammers
costs today a couple interesting ones is
that at the low range compromised
accounts in spam accounts are roughly
the same value you know I don't have a
good explanation for that but if you go
out into the ecosystem and end and you
want to buy accounts you can buy them at
about a thousand per time and it'll cost
you four fifty five dollars to obtain a
thousand accounts and exploit them for
spam the more the higher value accounts
tend to have proofs tied to them SMS
proofs and so on and also varies by
service a little bit depending on
whether you want gmail accounts or
hotmail or yahoo and so on another
interesting number is loads a thousand
freshly infected pcs can range anywhere
from eight dollars for a generic set of
thousand pcs up to four hundred dollars
where the PCs are geo-targeted you have
some knowledge of exactly where those
pcs are located and then the last one I
wanted to point out it is captcha
solving services at the far end
typically run in the range using
sweatshops and OCR type attacks anywhere
from about 70 cents up to a dollar
ninety person solutions so it costs
attackers basically 70 cents to create a
thousand new accounts
okay let's come back to compromise
because as I mentioned earlier this is a
painful painful part of the equation for
users these estimates they're uncertain
there's a lot of uncertainty this is one
of our big open research problems is how
do we figure out what are the main
sources of compromise but to the best
that we can estimate today we believe
about two-thirds of it comes from
malware an important thing is that is
really combination of malware plus
Windows Update hasn't run recently so we
think that less than 1% are really
zero-day attacks that there really is
it's unpatched machines that are left on
the internet and users download so an
exploit that could have been blocked but
wasn't about twenty percent is some
combination of unsecured third party
websites so a sequel injection impacts
like the yaku breach and then password
reuse and we saw from the Sony and
Gawker attacks i think it was in the
range of at the low end it was twenty
five percent of high end it was sixty
percent of users were reusing passwords
between the multiple sites were
compromised in the Gawker case so again
this is an ongoing concern especially
for a first party because we could have
you know bulletproof security but if the
whole ecosystem is insecure than then
all of those all of that password reuse
impacts us and our users and then the
other attacks kind of fall off the chart
so really the trade-off i think is
between malware and third-party posture
grieves in terms of where the most
uncertainty is we have reasonable handle
on the bottom set of numbers and I
should you know I can get up and and you
can say well of course your Microsoft
you're going to say first party exploits
are not a problem but we really believe
that's the case like you know as I
mentioned earlier compromises equal
opportunity it's impacting everyone and
if you look at the yahoo breach last
week that's kind of a third first party
exploit mind you is on a sub domain but
that impacted five percent of one day's
take of compromised accounts 405 percent
of 450,000 credentials that would be
so where is the industry going well this
is the password reuse problem is
definitely an ongoing concern mobile
malware and lack of policing in certain
app stores is becoming a bit of an issue
harvesters are becoming more
sophisticated they sort accounts they
check whether they're billing
relationships with counts and they'll
sell them you know for different prices
based on on what perceived value they
have in the account of use proxies are
becoming more geo-targeted I can say
well I know this account is from the
eastern seaboard from Philadelphia or
whatever and and rent an abuse proxy
that's in that geolocation also a higher
extent of identity theft that when you
purchase credentials you're not just
purchasing email credentials you're
getting a banking credit card
information and so on so I think I have
okay I'll have five minutes so I'll
blast through my last few slides when we
think about solutions now and really
it's not we can't solve abuse we need to
mitigate it we want to keep it contained
and controlled it's never going to go
away it's organized crime it's never
going to go away so we think about how
can we involve users more and protecting
their accounts how can we educate users
definitely we can take some obvious
steps like banging comment passwords use
two-factor authentication when when
users travel we can use smarter
antivirus solutions and build better URL
reputation systems to block malware from
reaching users boxes and behind that you
know develop our machine learning
capabilities what can we do in terms of
modeling abuse behind the scenes and use
that to inform user decisions I want to
give one good example where we've really
i think done a great job in containing
especially the malware problem and
that's the work we did in ie9 are
rethinking security dialogues so when
you download really I nine so I nine
smart screen includes this feature
called application reputation and when
you download
are you from the internet we check is
this flash is is this a binary that's
familiar that lots of users downloaded
safe to download if if it's safe the
download process is smooth there's no
spurious dialogue are you sure you want
to run this this came from outside
source and about nine times out of ten
that's the case the binary is totally
safe trusted we let through on in the in
the ten percent of the cases we get this
dialog you know this executable is not
downloaded commonly could harm your
machine and your options are to delete
ur or take additional actions and if you
click actions you get these wonderful
choices don't run the program or delete
the program and i love this dialog it's
great and if you really really
determined to run it you click more
options and there's an option to run it
but you've we really made the case of
the user that you know you're taking a
risk now this is a real risk this isn't
like just clicking through okay okay you
know i know i get this dialog all the
time i'm not going to i'm going to run
it anyways so from a intelligence
perspective we've kind of flipped the
problem on its head and said let's
identify the good stuff what are the
good things that users download how can
we build reputation about them we get
much fewer significantly fewer warnings
and they're very highly targeted and for
a typical user they might get two of
these warnings per year and when we look
at at the binaries that are later
determined to be malware later call it
by AV ninety-five percent of the time
the users are making the right decision
so imagine we've mitigated the malware
the download problem we've reduced the
effectiveness of an attack by
ninety-five percent that's really really
profound and you know I think we should
as an industry we should continue to
push in this direction okay I'm all
instead of time I want to talk a tiny
bit about machine learning those of you
that work in machine learning would look
at this rock urban think wow like that
you know the area under the curve is
tastic is really great separation of
positive and negative this is a
prototype for detecting abuse of use of
accounts but our tolerance for false
positives is extremely low right we
can't have a one-percent pulse positive
rate on half of half a billion users
that we've just not work so you know we
live very much at the very left hand end
of the curve trying to identify as much
abuse as we can while keeping the false
positive raised close to zero as
possible some open problems for the
community really the center one is the
big one that we try to tackle every day
is you know almost all of these reviews
abuse problems across the whole spectrum
like whether the users solving a hip or
sending an email or creating an account
what's the probability that this event
is malicious given all the signals that
we can collect about the event and
really you know there's some common way
of thinking about these problems at
least from an intelligence perspective
that we can apply and and great tools
and certainly big data has been very
useful to us in this space they're
definitely challenges the talkers are
very highly distributed we need to scale
out to handle hundreds of billions of
billions of requests our labels are not
always super crisp and we have very very
low tolerance for pulse pause news okay
just to call outs and I'm done the first
is this just in order to protect
yourselves check your hot in the state
of your Microsoft account your hotmail
account go to account live com make sure
your proofs are accurate and you can
remember them so later if you are
compromised you can give us the right
information you can recover your account
easily always using passwords goes
without saying and then lastly I do have
some space for research interns and if
you have any questions about this talker
or you have students that are interested
you can contact me at this email address
that's it thank you
that's a good question off the top of my
head no there's there's a handful of
and mike hearn at google gave an
interesting talk look earlier this year
and if you just search for my Colonel I
think you'll find it it's a videotaped
talk in it it's very similar in this is
speaking about the state of compromise
and and how Google is addressing the
problem otherwise it's yeah I don't have
a great answer either intentionally or
primary or you know some reason they
don't want to tell you right right yeah
that's a good point and and certainly
like with these warnings the technically
savvy users are always going to be like
oh I know what I'm doing right they'll
click through anyways in and they may in
fact you know be infected because of
that they're like oh I don't trust with
Microsoft is saying I think the bigger
picture is the App Store pitcher and and
there the jury's out on really whether
the walled garden is sufficient
protection and certainly in the Android
case I wasn't going to name any names
excuse me but in the Android case you
know the the lack of policing the App
Store has been an issue and you know I
think we asked an industry and
especially the AV industry will need to
get a handle on what does malware it
look like in the App Store and if the
user is consented to surrendering their
PII for example their personal
information is that really malware they
gave consent because they you know they
click through this app will upload your
contacts and so on that's you know in
the app manifest so yeah
a great way for you to collect the
binary and then run it in a some more
specialized environment and you say you
know the Chi result let's wait and then
you run it yes so there are technical
reasons why we can't do it at in the
moment we don't want to steal users
bandwidth but we definitely are
interested in collecting binary samples
and analyzing them so on ok let's thank
the speaker again so our second speaker
is Mike Ryder micah is lawrence ms
slipped king a distinguished professor
from unc chapel hill and before he
joined unc mike was a director of secure
systems research at bell labs and later
a professor at the cs and ECE department
of Carnegie Mellon University Mike got
the his PhD from Cornell and today he's
going to talk about the sophisticated
side-channel attacks happening in the
cloud great thanks can everyone hear me
great so Rob's talk was very much about
classes of attacks that are occurring at
massive scale today I'm going to be
talking about somethings a bit more
speculative than that but nonetheless is
something that's been casting a shadow
over the sprint to cloud computing and
and in terms of the possibility of a
type of attack that that might sort of
scare some people away from it let's put
that way if you aren't in the security
community may not have heard of these
things called side-channel attacks I'll
try to describe you what these are at a
very high level and give you a sense for
where things stand as they as a you know
increment in terms of current state of
the art i want to say i'm going to give
you good news and bad news i know that
when someone offers me that choice i
always say
bad news first and so that's what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start with
the bad news so first what is a side
channel this is a method for extracting
information from a computation based on
supplementation despite the fact that
the implementation may completely adhere
to the design of the algorithm and in
fact that the design is correct
oftentimes these kinds of attacks are
conducted to try to extract a
cryptographic key from someplace that it
shouldn't be extracted from that's not
the only thing you can do with them but
it's a very common type of attack and
that's something we'll talk about here
today now in particular immo stint arest
in the context of cloud computing there
is a class of side-channel attacks
called access driven side-channel
attacks the idea here is that the
attacker runs a program on the system
that is performing say a cryptographic
operation of interest and the basic idea
is to observe you use your your
beachhead on the machine the attack was
a beach home machine to observe the
computations affects the cryptographic
computations effects and then try to use
that information to extract the key and
recently most attacks that most progress
in the space is focused on what are
called asynchronous attacks where you
don't need specific timing associated
with when the operation was launched you
don't need to be able to start at any
particular moment and know exactly when
you start it that is the cryptographic
computation but rather you just get a
synchronous access to the system as the
cryptographic computation is going on
and then you glean information from that
this has been demonstrated in the
context of simultaneous multi-threaded
systems consequently they aren't as the
SMT is not employed typically in cloud
deployments and oftentimes they leverage
the ability to game the OS scheduler in
non virtualized environments we're going
to talk about the difficulties of doing
this
analogous sort of thing in virtualized
environments I want to say that to this
point no one has really shown how to do
this in a virtualized SMP setting which
is the one that we care about most for
for cloud as it relates to cloud issues
okay so i just want to remind you or you
know give you the the picture of a CPU
cache you're going to see this picture
on almost every one of my slides so I
thought I might as well explain it what
I have here is a 4-way set associative
cache with cash sets indicated in each
column each of one each cache set
consisting of multiple cache lines in
this case for and of course the way the
caches work is that when a physical
address is emitted for retrieval the
cash is checked first by mapping the
physical address to a cache set and then
looking in there to see whether or not
you have the data already and of course
if you don't then you have to go get it
so that's I just wanted to sort of give
you that picture because we're going to
be seeing a lot of this now a very
common trick in the context of
side-channel attacks that make use of
caches is something called a prime probe
protocol not our invention this is
something that's done quite a bit and I
don't know why the bad graphic change
that's not the graphic that I put in the
slides but this is the attacker who is
conducting a prime protocol essentially
by filling up the cash with his own data
and going away then something happens he
waits for a while called that we're
going to refer to as the prime probe
interval during which something else
runs and accesses things brings other
things into cash evicting the attackers
data and then subsequently the attacker
comes back and starts timing the amount
of time it takes to retrieve data out of
the tree the same data that they initial
into the cache and what you'll what's
going to happen here is that the
attacker goes through the cash he will
get to see what was evicted or what cash
sets data was evicted from by looking at
the amount of time it takes to retrieve
all the data that should have been there
had it not been evicted okay and so by
doing this by by walking through the
cash you can get a sense for what
happened while he was gone and it might
seem a bit surprising but you can then
leverage this this basic approach to
loan information about for example a
cryptographic key that was being used so
that's the basic idea of what this prime
probe protocol is all about now the this
has been studied quite a bit in the
context of non virtualized settings so
you know your typical situation where
you have an attacker process running
next to a victim process on an operating
system and you that you know the
attacker process Prime's the cache waits
a while comes back probes the cash and
says oh i see they access these cash
sets and so on and so forth and let me
figure out what I can from that when you
move to a virtualized setting of course
there's some more software that's in
play and these extra layers of software
cloud the picture from the attackers
point of view this is one of the big
reasons that it's been very hard to pull
off these kinds of attacks in the
context of virtualized settings now a
little more specifically I wanted to
sort of highlight what some of the
challenges are in this domain one of
them is that in general needs
virtualized settings for example you
take the default credit scheduler and
then the scheduling quantum is very
coarse what that means is that the
notion of the attacker going away and
coming back later it's like going away
for a year and coming back later and see
your entire crate you know all your data
evicted roughly speaking right you have
it's a very coarse signal and it doesn't
permit very many observations for
ampulla crypto operation if at all right
so you have to figure out was this a
crypto is a cryptographic operation
indicated in the cache and how do I get
any information from the fact that
virtually everything I had put in there
is now evicted okay because a lot of
things could have run in that time so
that's one challenge that is a real
problem in this domain a second problem
is that in these virtualized settings
virtualize us in peace settings there
are a number of sources of cash noise
and there's no way in the short amount
of time i have here that I can go
through all these different sources and
how to deal with them but everything
from you know power saving you know
turning off CPUs or coors when they're
not being used to of course the
hypervisor and dom0 getting in the way
these are the extra software layers i'm
talking about one that we're going to
come back to later is Dom 0 which is an
administrative domain again this is not
the the graphic I had for it but it'll
do so this is the dawn 0 sorry so Dom 0
is basically an administrative domain
that takes care of various things on the
platform and when it gets control of
course it can run through and completely
mess up your cash and this isn't going
to show anything about the the
cryptographic operation that the victim
virtual machine was doing and so when
the probe comes back and looks through
it seems a lot of noise from dom0 and
really doesn't know what to do from that
okay another challenge here is the the
problem of core migration and what I
mean by that is you have your attacker
that Prime's the cash and then goes away
all right waiting for the victim ideally
what happens is here comes the victim
again new graphic for the victim and the
victim does it sting leaves its marks in
the cash goes away and
tacker gets to come back and look and
see what happens right this is what the
attacker is hoping for well what really
happens in these SMP environments of
course is that sometimes right the
attacker will back out and here we'll
come down zero just migrated over and
mess up his cash you get then he leaves
and now when the attacker comes back of
course you see something that doesn't
involve the cryptographic operation at
all and so it's important in terms of
inferring any information about a
cryptographic key that you even be able
to recognize when there's a signal in
there at all so another again another
one of these challenges now in the in
the amount of time i have there's really
no way i can describe to you all the
different steps one has to take you get
through all these but i didn't want to
just give you the 30,000 foot view of
how we've been able to make progress on
this problem so it involves multiple
different ingredients one of them
involves gaming is n scheduler to be
able to interrupt the victim with
sufficient frequency so that were not
bound by this 30 mil second interval the
scheduling quantum in terms of being
able to observe what the victims do is
so we're able to shrink that time quite
a bit by gaming the Zen scheduler a
second ingredient is coming up with ways
of classifying cash pattern observations
first individually and then in a
sequence so we use you know standard
machine learning techniques support
vector machines hidden Markov models
things like this to be able to interpret
whether or not an observation we see out
of the cash is in fact useful for
learning something about the key of a
victim and then subsequently looking at
the sequence and then extracting
information out of the sequence to try
to indicate in this particular case what
a secret exponent of a module
exponentiation operation is now the
reason we feel
this on that of course is if you know
cryptography you know that that
particular operation is something that's
very fundamental in many cryptographic
algorithms of a public key variety and
so we've been targeting those kinds of
operations here this process of
classifying cash pattern observations
yields a collection of what we call
execution fragments which you can almost
think of as little snippets of the
exponentiation operation and each one
being a conjecture of what the bits of
the exponent the big secret were after
might be in that window in which we saw
it now again because we have an
asynchronous attack here we don't really
know where in the window where in that
exponent that might fall but we have
some small snippet of a possible
exponent and then what we do is we apply
customized sequence reconstruction
reconstruction algorithms to try to
piece all of these together it's very
much like a sequence reconstruction in
the bioinformatics sense where you start
with you know some very small snippets
of a very long sequence you try to line
them up in the best way you can and
figure out what the key is at that point
that gives us something we call a key
template which still has a lot of errors
and then from there we just have to
exhaustively search the remaining key
possibilities one thing I want to tell
you about is an experiment that we have
done to show that this can work out what
we did is we attack the implementation
of El Gamal decryption in particular in
G crypt version 15 if you're not
familiar with all of them all decryption
don't worry about it it's just we're
after the secret exponent again and we
utilized in this case the instruction
cache using Zen for dough and if you're
familiar with the distinction between
work conserving and non work conserving
scheduling
we did this on a work conserving
schedule we've also done it on a not
working work conserving scheduling ger
okay now in this particular case we were
attacking what is by today's standards a
ridiculously stupid least wrong key of
4096 bit el gamal modulus which you know
i think to a first approximation by
today's standards would take until the
heat death of the universe to crack
something like this the private exponent
was 457 bits and what we did is we set
up the victim to repeatedly perform
decryptions as if they could be
triggered by the attacker and it for
example if it was a web server the
victim was a web server the attacker
could send queries to the web server to
cause it to do these decryptions over
and over again this is really not
fundamental to the attack this is just
something to speed it up if we we could
we again we've implemented the
classifiers on the cache patterns to
filter out readings that don't reflect a
key and there are many readings that
still don't reflect the key but this
just allowed us to make progress on the
attack faster it took us about 30
million prime probe trials over the
course of six hours in this setup but
after doing that in several hours more
of computation in terms of the sequence
alignments and things like that we're
able to narrow down the key space to
about 10,000 possibilities which of
course is easily searchable at that
point and so this is kind of the
punchline the bad news right which is
that this kind of side channel attack
does appear to be possible in this
context and unfortunately it sort of
affirms a fear that many people have had
about the move to to cloud computing
that that these virtualized SMP
environments still permit this kind of
information to be extracted okay so I
have about 10 minutes 7 minutes left
okay fair enough
so what I'll do now is I'll transition
to the maybe the good news now a
reaction to this kind of attack is to
say well what we should do is try to
physically isolate virtual machines that
you really care about the security for
that is that have cryptographic
operations going on and so forth an
example of this and I think this was
largely spurred by a preceding work to
this particular one I told you about was
amazon now offers of course dedicated
instances if you want to run pay a
little more you can have your tasks
physically isolated in the cloud now the
trouble of course here is that typically
cloud providers don't give you
visibility into the platform to confirm
that in fact you're receiving physical
isolation that you promised and this you
could imagine of course things that that
could the ways that this physical
isolation promise might be violated
would be a configuration error on the
part of the the cloud provider or maybe
just taking shortcuts get lower costs
temporarily for some reason we're not
really focused here on an arbitrarily
malicious cloud provider because I think
at that point you're a little bit stuck
but what we are worried about here is
that you want to just be sure that the
cloud provider if they said you're
getting physical isolation you will get
it and we're assuming here the cloud
customer really doesn't have any control
or visibility into the platform of the
virtualization layer and consequently
their verification and auditing is
difficult so I'd in a different project
that we've been working on what we've
done is we turn side channels on their
head and we said look if we can use them
as an attack vector we could also use
them for the good guys to figure out if
they are in fact running alone on a
platform that they've been told they'll
be running a loan on and we tend to
think of this in true in terms of two
classes of vm as the friendly ones the
ones that you put out there i want to
run
and what we call the fovea mess or the
ones that you don't want there and
that's indicated by the ! in the
triangle again not my choice but that's
what we'll work with so yeah so that's
the fobian over there on the right Wow
okay I really should look through these
this here so now those are the friendly
VMs the little people standing there the
basic way this is going to work is that
the friendly VMs are going to coordinate
to identify in this case a cache region
that they are going to actively avoid
using and the reason they going to do
that is because they're going to
periodically look in there and see if
there has been any activity because if
there has been it wasn't one of them
okay and if it wasn't one of them they
need to figure out what's going on okay
so that's the basic problem so here what
we have is we have the system running oh
my okay and system running they're using
the cash but you'll notice nothing ever
flashed in here okay so they are
actively avoiding that cash region so
okay so to get this kind of thing to
work there's a few things that we had to
do and in the interest of time I'm going
to blow through this very fast one of
them is then well how do you get how do
you actually avoid part of your cash
well in the case we were working with
pvm as NP vm in this case and what we do
is we essentially remap memory to avoid
the part of the cash that we decide
sorry too so the friendlies don't mess
up the part of the cash they're avoiding
so the way that works roughly speaking
is there's a mapping in Zen from pseudo
physical pages which is the abstraction
exported to the VMS down to physical
pages and pvm gives you enough
visibility in that mapping to understand
when you have a physical memory
configuration that would walk on the
part of the cash you're trying to avoid
so what you now do
you remap things you move things around
so that you no longer touch the part of
the cash that you carry that you want to
avoid I'm just going to skip through the
details of this in the interest of time
there's a nice basically you copy the
data out of where you you need to avoid
to somewhere else that you set up in
advance and then you you set things up
so that you aren't going to touch that
part of the cash anymore so this is what
the friendlies are going to do to avoid
the part of the cash they've decided to
use the second thing that happens
remember this is our new dom0 simple is
that the was so or one thing that we we
have to deal with in this case is that
dom0 him sell itself can we can't change
dom0 to not use the part of the cash
that the friendlies decide to avoid
right we can't change the platform so it
can come through and okay this is
completely messed up it can come through
and walk all over the part of the cash
that the friendlies are trying to avoid
and it means that when you get these
probe results out of that part of the
cash you have some degree of confusion
as to whether that's actually a faux or
whether that's just dom0 and maybe the
hypervisor and other things going on
that should be there so we had to do is
build a classifier for what activity
looks like on the platform in the
absence of a foe in the part of the cash
region that you're avoiding it very
roughly what you end up getting is a
bimodal distribution in terms of your
progra souls that really breaks down in
our platform down to two cases in our
case we were working in the l2 cache
that each l2 cache was shared across two
cores and there were really two
configurations we had to worry about one
was that there was a friendly on one l2
cache and dom0 was on the other l2 cache
and that would give you with this part
of this big spike here the other
possibility was that dom0 was also on
the l2 cache that the friendly doing the
monitoring was on in which case you get
this other bump in the distribution just
to cut to the chase we use this
observation
build a classifier where basic
essentially the presence of a foe will
push you to the right in the
distribution and so what we have to do
is we have to look at a number of
observations over time and then figure
out what's the likelihood of this having
happened if there was no foe one thing
that makes this a little harder is that
in fact that distribution shifts on the
basis of the amount of work that dom0
has to do what changes that well
primarily it's what the friendlies are
doing so every time we take one of these
readings we have to sort of think about
it in the context of what the friendly
viens were doing at the time and
interpret it differently okay but that's
the so that's one of the big challenges
in building this but let me just sort of
summarize then in the end how this ends
up working what we do is we declare the
the cache region to avoid we hand off
monitoring responsibilities to one of
the VMS this vm which is now the monitor
will watch for activity using a prime
probe protocol here and interpret the
results in light of what it sees and
then hands off responsibility to another
friendly vm and again the reason it in
that first step the part that wasn't
shown here was that the friendlies
avoided remaps their memory to avoid
that part of the cash so they could use
it for monitoring ok so anyway it sort
of works or well it works pretty well
actually but I've been told with a big
large sign to wrap up so I'm wrapping up
quickly the bad news which is the first
thing I told you about was it again
cross vm side channels do appear to be
possible in virtualized SMP environments
the good news however is that by turning
side channels on their head we can
essentially use them to confirm that vm
friendly VMs are physically isolated
from one another if you're willing to
pay the costs in the context of cloud
computing for physical isolation okay
thank you so I guess Mike wrapped up a
very much in time and this always do
have time for a few questions I see so
the question is so as a defensive
measure against the first class of
attacks introduce additional noise into
the cache yeah so I think it's a really
interesting idea it's not something
we've explored the Spence's of doing
that and what it means to the
performance of the applications you care
about is unclear I think that's one
thing you have to worry about the other
thing is how much randomness you really
have to inject so that the attached you
have confidence the attacker is not just
slowed down by a small factor of two or
three but you've really stopped the
attack and I think that's the hard part
and that approach but that's a knee-jerk
reaction we have an experimental bit at
all it's a really interesting idea
information on the vm i also on the
native operating environment and what
else might be present how beautiful is
that likely to be in practice you have
that another yeah that's an excellent
point so I blew through the evaluation
so fast so you did what you're pointing
out is that there's a training phase
where you need to train the classifier
on the platform you're going to be
running on in the cloud absolutely yeah
that's right so there's a few things you
can try one is do a trust on first use
model right which is you know well-known
tofu model will use this all the time
and security you cross your fingers and
hope the first time it's working out
fine collect your data train on it and
so forth the other approach you can take
is to replicate a
the class of machine that you're going
to be have access to in the cloud by one
instance train there then put put things
out those are two models that we've
thought of so far yeah I mean so I think
most of this has to do with the hardware
configuration the machine so it is not
so I mean not entirely you're absolutely
right but there's I don't see it
changing that frequently yeah okay let's
thank the speaker again so our final
speaker itself on one he's associate
professor from school of informatics and
computing from Indiana University
Bloomington chiffon currently serving as
a director of IU Center for Security
informatics and he got his PhD from ECE
department of Carnegie Mellon University
and so Mike told us impose some bad news
and good news and so in the first stop
we've seen a lot of attacks and Michelle
phone is also going to tell us some more
bad news in the first part of stock
attacks a tax that abuse online
advertising channels at the end over
here also tell us some good news I'm
detecting a second problem may be some
good news yellow just and mice nice not
starting to be different from others
right you know just an apologize i
haven't the formatted as a Microsoft
week but a good thing she is I don't
have to travel Microsoft prob right it
won't get a messed up it will
authenticate to the original form let's
see what's going to happen and now so
first you know just I'm very happy to
have these chunks to talk about our web
security research here you know just a
recently years waiting Dida has a
wonderful wonderful journey on the web
so and you know just and it's a
wonderful because we did a bunch of
nasty things right and here's what we
did we're trying to figure out how much
you earn and you know just and your what
can disease you have how did you invest
by simply looking at yellow right now I
can use these terms die the channel
which produced by web application then
and we shop for free and again the stuff
we really don't deserve and try to log
into other people's account by cracking
those small peace not peace third-party
web api integration and then you know
just the more recently we're trying to
advertise to you something you really
don't want just like malware infection
right and they just threw the party you
may trust it just like a new york time
and you know just and don't just bring
these things to us you know just well
not that bad right we cannot do this
without our Microsoft our company's
register NSO here I least the name of
those who are you gotta guilty on the
slides you know just a little around let
me find some of them but today I'm going
to talk about you know gesture and all
reason the work mauritius at worth
hiding you know against the journey work
with microsoft research and what we're
trying to do is we want we call these
things merit hiding right well Julie's
turns generically register and trying to
refer to a broad category of attack just
like drive-by download and the skin
click fraud as long as it goes through
the web at hiding channel so you know
today if you go to those a big publisher
web page in York Times I'll be very
surprised if you don't bump into those
banner ads right you know just they're
everywhere which is understandable
because you know just under the general
revenue for the publishers many
publishers live on that but given the
important given important rose to those
where the web adult hiding playing the
web ecosystem you know it comes with e
to surprise you know just and the people
spend a lot of effort there make it more
effective right and so right now this
web advertising business has already
developed into a very complicated form
right so if we talk about Edward hiding
we are no longer talking about just
advertiser and publisher we're talking
about
big system a very complicated system
right well publisher we have adult
either we're bunch of people stay in
between and for example we have those ad
network Alex change so they sell the
road just like a matchmaker and trying
to bring advertiser to a publisher and
publisher to advertise there's some
other parties which bowling styling
traffic and doing targeting and the you
know just all this behavior the system
become very complicated so the common we
study is if we have a complicated system
the more complicated it is and you legit
the more difficult to get it right right
to get a secure and this also happen to
these online Edward hiding system back a
few years ago yellow just an ephemeris
instances one day when people with it
and this new york times so here's what a
greeting then right it's a freak AV you
know just pad it is not an original one
right I just want to show these things
happen no just that is a really big
issue and it because it looks like New
York Times is kind of promoting malware
trees customer right this kind of stuff
it jump out of York Times web page it
looks like you know just the credible
right people make click on that once you
did it you get a screw up so how could
this happen how could New York Times
such a big repute reputable you know
advertiser publisher and end up
promoting malware to their customer to
understand you know just how could these
things happen geologists we need to take
close look at this in online advertising
eulogist procedure today imagine your ad
network if we want to publish it
publishes something on New York Times
what you need to do is a given add a tag
to the publisher sony real-time embedded
is a tag into its content right so
whenever someone where did you know the
you know the New York Times web page
it's brought his browser will
automatically interpret this tag and
execute a troll so what's happening at
this guy's browser will go to ad network
and try to grab the ad right if the ad
network does not have a right thing to
post it there they may resale the space
to the other network right so in this
case
or what you get from our network is just
a simple redirection it will redirect
you to another network and try to get
the right ad service in first right so
this procedure we call add a syndication
you know just it become it can become
very complicated so as you can see here
with at a syndication you know just
actually the publisher has little
control on you know just what will be
posted to the end user when the bad
things happen they don't even know who
responsible for that right because it
could be further down this syndication
chain you don't know which linker the
bad things happen so the whole things
become very complicated and give its
complication right and an effective
mitigation of you know merit hiding
threat become very difficult so a lot of
people have studied these neurologist
this type of this problem and at their
branch of work here I don't think I have
time to go through than one by one and
all this approach and the you know just
made progress in the area and the
succeed and to some extent but you know
just an important feature here socio
trying to looking at individual
identities behavior on the ad delivery
chain right eulogy for example if you
work on code analysis you want to take a
close look at the ad being delivered to
the user looking at its content a fight
out of those contain malicious code for
example we believe they're important
aspect and ism which has been mr. here
and which are the potential to provide a
new way to knock out the whole thing you
know just and just as mention those
previous research they focus on
individual identity so we're talking
about you know just today if you want to
do this mellow tiling business you know
there's more than one entity it's a
whole infrastructure out there like your
attacker has a multiple party they work
together and try to deliver you know
just as to victimize the other so we are
looking at these things from the
relation between and different entity
we're asking question how this you know
infrastructure look like and whether to
prod you look like and we're searching
for me
in just enough obtained from these this
kind understanding we believe we can
develop a new technique that
accompaniment complemented existing
content based approach and you know just
and to better protect user from Wow
hiding so you know just as a first step
we perform Marvin study on my own
marriage hiding you know just our
objective is we want to understand the
scale at a magnitude of the problem we
want to you know just and look at the
the features of individual notes that is
URL during a delivery chain and the
relation between the nodes which
describe the feature of the whole
infrastructure and then based on such
information you know just we come up
when you detach an approach which tell
us to work pretty well and we outperform
the existing you know blackness that
malware scanner just like you know just
to google see browsing and microsoft
forefront by 15 times in terms of number
of you know just a malicious case being
detected so must specifically in the
last year you know throughout the gym to
September we'll use child virtual
machine you know just repeatedly crore
the top nine thousand Alexa website
right and all objective is we're trying
to extract and those add a related
redirection chain for example you know
just and once you with this affray
unlike gamescom right what do you ever
see is it is that a requester to double
creek then found double connect it will
further redirect you to as Notre com
which is an odd other network so this
just gave us this add a redirection
chain right you know from free online
games com to devil kitty cat interesno
de calm and the way identified those the
reduction change related to related it
to you know I'm not hiding using you
know easy list and the either privacy
and these are two knees to which correct
all the features and they use for
detecting at a ready to the URLs and in
this case you know just we found no
double-click is really to Edward hiding
because it has you know just this
special feature now over the
over the you know just to add a
religious redirection chain we
discovered and we run forefront and
exceed browsing on the individual node
here one node is a URL and we're trying
to find out you know just detect those
malicious case right malicious and that
you know just an accountant delivery
pass so we found that you know just
almost a thousand militias case here a
case I'm talking about is Adam impasse
that is every mode on the past actually
the domain right and so you in this way
we can generalize the things we found
and because you know just a lot of URL
paths and as a actually share seemed to
me the just each time they use a
slightly different in URL pattern and
then we found about 386 in fact
publishers and a bunch of malicious node
and the malicious to me and at sm we
also discover multipro my with hiding
campaigns the shorter one master to the
short one takes three days in the number
one you know just a nasty two months so
here's exemplar if we read this website
frog calm and then you know just it will
generate a request to double-click then
double-click you will unfortunately in
this time apparently they were
infiltrated and it will bring you to as
nola.com which is a malicious malicious
you know just add a network so that one
will bring you to a redirector so
finally and you will hit the target
which is the attack server so
interestingly during this process every
step of the notice on this attack pass a
diversity you know just to take some
very serious magnet into hydrogen the
cell from detection for example as know
their account it will randomly pick up
redirector each time center to move you
to to the next step and then you know
just you're in the and the redirector we
will randomly pick up one out of 80's
84cm website you know to move your
browser to and also those those
individual nodes that they purport we
perform the Oppo phone complicated
cloaking right there knocking out of
your IP address looking either you are
you the agent before they can take the
further action
once we obtain those you know just
confirmed a malicious pass and now we
take a close look at individual notes
and trying to fight their feature
interestingly you know just to end up
and for those malicious nodes right over
ninety percent of them looks like having
last thing to do with adult hiding so so
that is we you this eating these two
either privacy to scan and right and
they just ended and they are marked as
unknown all right we all go card in the
G tomato nose legitimate notes and I
just at least of the nose we don't find
any problem you know just from and and
you know just only less than eight
percent of then you know just seems
nothing to do with Edward hiding and in
other words you're just over ninety two
percent of their you know just very much
rated to add right and also no car there
who is the information you know just the
formulations demain over seventy percent
of them you know just registering one
year and expiring one here which is
understandable we trust and you know
just an attacker they want to keep their
costs a damn right if you register short
period of time so you know the distant
costs it could be lower well legitimate
ones taken on their time then we just
like many other web based attack and the
day you this freedom main door co CC and
they have the URL pattern but all these
are the features we gather from a single
node a single URL right end up they are
interesting but if we want to use all
these features for detection it turned
out to be not very effective it simply
cost too much for astrology so so that
means we cannot just to focus on
individual ndd we need to go beyond data
when you to knock out a relation between
between those entities right so we're
not with rustic look we quickly look at
the relation between those malicious
pair so we are talking about then those
a neighboring node right and you know
just interestingly and we refers to come
to their frequency in the chain data set
interestingly enough photos appear
frequently let's see you know it haven't
trans at very least and then you know
just and most of them are good one right
and a well for those appear you know
just another very frequent once or twice
and a manner of them actually a
malicious so this understandable we
trust you know for legitimate parties
and the
in between those had a synergist and
describe the authentic business
tradition and that this should be a kind
of stable then the largest and those
malicious products also you know you
know just as observed in previous
research and affordable issues and the
further malicious in the content
delivery passes they are significant and
long does an illegitimate a wine right
the most amazing things to observe it is
in some case where you you hit to the
you know distant now at hiding case
right you without doing any creaking we
didn't do any creaking you know just the
whole the whole things just going on
you'll note by you know just to a to
light hops so it automatically bring us
across your registered hi Ohio's it's
kind of shocking well you know just in
from the jetta major case it is you know
just pretty moderate one not true and
maximize you wanna just 24 and then add
a syndication indeed a big use issue
over sixty percent across by this
problem and a bad guys they tend to stay
together right so these were to observe
you know just to end up well you're
looking at today we're starting from
those confirmed malicious node that is
the ones that you tagged by see browsing
and forefront then with no car their
neighborhood and typically waiting for
hops winning for hops you know just to
end up and that those node and looks
very suspicious and because they also
sitting on a lot of other but it should
confer number issues you know just the
content delivery pass well if we look
further let's go to five or six hub
which answer then also shared by other
just a malicious content content
delivery paths become very very know so
what does that means that I mean if we
want to capture the main feature of
infrastructure right and you know we
don't need to know how to hope has which
are too complicated maybe only you to
look at a short sequence with three or
four most it's good enough to capture
you know just and many merit hiding
infrastructure at least you know
according to all the data we gathered we
do have a disappearing so what we did is
you know just and we're using this idea
and a short sequence you know just to
we've come up when you detach the
approach at the approach is very simple
straightforward about it performs
surprisingly well and though i know we
use we use three know the sequence right
then you know just each time situation
all that we just
voyage of wisdom and the information
attributed just like and a frequency
jaws you know what can I wrote publisher
at unknown and domain registration time
and URL pattern you know just enter then
again those feature if we use an unknown
it does not work well the power of our
approach is just putting into contacts
bridges and UNICEF sequence then you in
the training data side to images to end
up and we check those chops or sequence
your statistical learning to
automatically generated detection rule
and then we evaluated them on the you
know just training untested data set you
know just I guess I just have time to
talk one of them and the you know just
and the interestingly in the data set of
a gathering October and then we
discovered 391 you know just to
compromise the website and a compare
what can can can be can be done you know
can be what can be detected by see
browsing and forum which only get only
gonna get a hundred eleven that's a
forty percent of what we get and when we
come to the case that is a you know just
mellow tithing you know just a domain
pass we get a four thousand and a 72
we'll see browsing and fall from
together only gal 258 that means we just
detect you know just almost the 15 times
you know just as many as a mare with
hiding case as you know just sleep
routing for from those come to miss
detection can get and also we detect
fast much much faster than those
approach you know just average of ten
point five days ahead of tea browsing so
I guess I have one minister quickly go
through you know just a new attack your
thumb and this is valuable because that
means we don't not only can we detect
those you know no attack but also can
capture us and people never know before
so this a new type of Creek Florida are
just different of unconventional click
for which youth click board right and
this we found that this type of things
actually the at attack a directly in bad
I frame into you know just compromise
the website so when you go to those
compromised website it automatically
generated for you in the creek and
ascended to we call dog doggy search
engine so that search engine
just and if you go there search anything
right it just come up with a link and
pointed to the malicious website and
don't click on that and that and then
you know just to end adult the doggy
search engine for water those four down
in the creek to a legitimate or
illegitimate you know just a paper
kkithika and that work levi.com okay so
you know just to end that so in this
case you know just ended it looks like
they're trying to get revenue out of it
I need to quickly wrap up on fridge
Anthony so concluding is merit hiding
indeed a big issue you know one percent
of odisha infected and you know just and
also a lot of reputable and network just
like you know double Creek was
infiltrated and on an ax handle we show
you know infrastructure view you need to
provide a new angle to look at this
problem and it's quite a promising you
know just Oh approaches single you know
straight Florida but still it caught to
you know just the 15 times them you know
just as many as Mao Italian cases then
those content based approach now you
know just as so in the future we believe
we show just combines together and the
you know just and using for example our
approach to generate as a high toxic you
know just flow and then use county-based
analyzer and a trigonal figure out to
validate a result and that approach
could also be installed on any you the
front you know just another user to
identify those official uio before they
step into that because I approach is
much lighter weight right it's much
simpler and so ill just here's my talk I
will be mother had paid answer your
question I'm friction than the icing at
on skis off